okay let's talk a little bit about
health care is health care or right or
is it a privilege I think it's alright I
think it needs to be a right I believe
it needs to be right as well in a
utopian society absolutely everyone
should have everything but this is not
its reality and you know I actually had
some very strong feelings on you know a
single pair sits down like it's my
husband works for a pharmaceutical
company it would be devastating to our
family if we went to a single pair my
husband also had cancer last year after
he went through chemo he had he went
through another treatment that boosted
his immune system but he was on like a
Facebook support group and he saw other
people from Australia from the UK not
able to receive that treatment they
weren't approved for it Jessica
fundamentally I believe it's a privilege
but one we should absolutely be working
towards it's just sharing everybody can
access your for example I don't have
health insurance I never have my
family's ever available afford it so I
think and it's actually worked for us
well are you worried that you don't have
health insurance or is that by choice
it's by choice
currently but my circumstances will
change and I know that at some point I
will need that option I just have a
question for you um how did you feel
about being taxed for not having health
insurance over and under the Affordable
Care Act sidesteps attacks by having a
Christian health care ministry which is
basely catastro yeah yeah
but that I mean that is a point where I
don't think you should be forced to have
health insurance but also if we want
people to have health care where's the
funny going to come from and that's a
really difficult question can you
understand the fundamental issue at the
heart of it which is you need healthy
people to buy insurance right so that
sick people can also get married care
right it's it's the catch-22 of the
system if you ask people with socialized
medicine lecture what do they think of
it they're gonna tell you it doesn't
it's not good they're not happy right
America has some of the best health care
in the world if you look at the waiting
list the you go these people go and
they're told that they have to wait like
eight plus months for the
a doctor's visit that they need to see
with the specialist or whatever the
mammogram or
whatever it is and at that point they
could be dead because they you in
certain situations with like high risk
high risk cancers and things like that
you got to be seen quick you can't you
can't wait that long
like people are dying in socialist
countries with health care she want to
say yeah I'd like to just interject
because that I mean that does happen
with socialized medicine when the system
is overwhelmed with there's only so many
facilities and there's everyone is
counting on them we have private
insurance that my husband pays a portion
of through his employer we have really
good insurance and we're really lucky
and I've been waiting five weeks to get
an MRI approved I have nerve pain I'm
losing sensation in my body and I'm a
lucky person so yeah health care is all
right if I couldn't get any kind of
health care it could not be able to move
the entire right side of my body so for
for people to say like oh well it's you
know it's all about ideals and it's a
utopian wish that everyone could get
health care everyone can get health care
how do we pay for it is a separate issue
do we have different levels of if this
is income based is it need-based there's
solutions but I think to say that it's a
privilege that even the privileged
people can't access when you're the one
who's supposed to be so privileges so
you're saying even when you do there's
so much there's so much that goes beyond
like how the insurance great how you
still can't get any help